until the rush of blood is a virtual
reality game for PlayStation VR on
PlayStation 4 it's a rollercoaster ride
a shooter experience and all the descent
into madness of one of our characters
from untold or so taking some key
scenarios and things that we know from
until dawn and approaching them in a
very very different way in until dawn
one of the key things was the branching
storyline you know the choices you made
had impact so this is until dawn rush of
blood it's a very different style of
game but it wouldn't be a game when the
untold autumn world if we didn't have
choices and the impact so I'm not gonna
give anything away about how we're
implementing it but rest assured there
are going to be decisions and choices
you make while you're playing Russia
blood that will impact the rest of the
game and impact how you play so we felt
VR was a great fit for horror because
the immersion level of VR you know it's
incredibly different when you put that
headset on and you're there in the world
and we have the aspects of you having
your arms in front of you and you can
look down and see yourself we've been
working with Sony on PlayStation VR
since early 2013 experimenting with VR
we built a demo from one of the very
early demonstrations called Jurassic
encounter as we were developing until
dawn and developing the VR experiences
simultaneously we worked out what sort
of experiences worked really really well
in VR and then as we were working that
out it became really obvious that the
world and the characters and the
environments we were creating for until
dawn would be a really great fit for
putting in a completely different way
and delivering as a VR game experience
for the players